MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
In this chapter, we will
talk about neutrinos.
And we'll start the discussion
with a relatively simple
introduction.
How does a neutrino look
in the standard model,
and how does it interact?
We have discussed the
neutrino already quite a bit.
So this is more
or less a summary.
In the standard model,
the neutrino is massless.
It's a massless particle.
And it interacts with
a weak direction.
So it interacts with w
bosons and with z bosons.
And specifically,
it does not interact
with photons of gluons.
If we look at the Lagrangian or
try to write down the current,
we find that there is a
charged current via the w.
And there is a neutral
current, we have the z boson.
It's quite interesting to
think about those two currents
a little bit more.
So in case of a charged
current, for example,
I have an incoming neutrino,
we can determine the flavor,
the kind of neutrino we have.
We are detecting the
flavor of the lepton.
So if, for example, identify
an electron in this interaction
in the interaction,
the initial neutrino
was an electron neutrino.
While for the neutral current,
when we have some sort
of interaction happening,
we cannot identify directly
the neutrino.
Hence, we cannot find the
flavor of the neutrino.
You can just measure the sum
of all flavors of neutrinos
in the neutral current.
On that story, neutrinos
have three flavors.
They come in electron flavor,
muon favor, or tau flavor.
Neutrinos are left-handed.
Anti-neutrinos are right-handed.
So that's the story.
That's how neutrinos
are characterized
in the standard model.
In the standard model, in
the framework we set up,
we can calculate cross-sections,
scattering cross-sections.
And here, we are looking in
the neutrino nuclei scattering.
Again, we can split this up in
the charged current and neutral
current discussion.
But they go very
much in parallel.
So we have elastic scattering.
Or in the case of
the charged current,
we talk about
quasi-elastic scattering.
Then we have an
incoming neutrino,
let's say a muon neutrino,
hitting a neutron,
producing a muon and a proton.
It's called quasi-elastic,
because we do not
break up the target,
but we change its kind.
So we change from a neutron
to a proton, in this case.
While, for the
elastic scattering,
the neutron just stays intact.
We can also have nuclear
resonance production,
where we hits the nuclei.
And then inside the nuclei,
we could use a [INAUDIBLE],,
like a neutral or a
charged [? pion. ?]
And also, that's possible in
the neutral current exchange.
And then we have
deep-inelastic scattering,
where we hit a nuclei
or nucleon that hard,
that we'd start breaking it up.
And in this case, we
scatter off the quark,
and we produce a new quark in
the charged current interaction
in the same quark in the
neutral current interaction.
So this is no different from
the stories we had before.
The intriguing part about
studying neutrino scattering
is that we do know that we
have weak interactions being--
we use a dominant force
of being the process.
While, if we use
photons to interact,
or we have electrons
being [INAUDIBLE],,
then we can have a mixture
of weak and electromagnetic
interaction.
Another important
takeaway from this slide
is that, when we
calculate cross-section,
we find that a linear
increase in the cross-section
of the function of the energy.
So while cross-sections
for neutrinos are small,
at higher energy source
cross-sections scale linearly.
As we can discuss this for
neutrino scattering with nuclei
and nucleons, we can also
look at neutrino scattering
with electrons directly.
There's a lot of electrons
in the metal around us.
And the neutrino [INAUDIBLE]
with this metal that can
interact with electrons, too.
And they can live in the charged
current interaction of muon
in an electron neutrino and in
a neutral current interaction
in electron in the [INAUDIBLE].
Also, here, you see
cross-section, total
cross-section scaled
with [INAUDIBLE] energy.
Good.
It's the first introduction
to neutrino physics.
We'll go into more detail in
the following presentations.